california there was a fire
from a gender reveal reveal and by the
way i don't know if you've seen
when they do these gender reveals what
it looks like this is kind of what it
looks like this is not the exact one
but watch this gender reveal party went
terribly wrong
a gender reveal party you see the fire
okay that fire ended up costing
80 million dollars but this is two years
ago
it means this is just an example of a
gender reveal
now go back go back guy
and show the other video of what just
happened in california right now 7 000
acres right there you can play that one
that's one of them rick you won't
believe how this fire started more on
that in just a moment from our vantage
point
the flames have died down a bit but this
is still a very active and dangerous
wildfire threatening homes
about evacuation orders because of
course that's what's on everybody
and the north bench you caipa
specifically by the way
like boulevard and east but it's not a
movie
no no does this blaze mean it was a boy
or girl yeah when you cover nine
mountain tops i think that's a boy by
the way that kid is gonna end up either
being someone that could cause
armageddon or that kid's gonna change
the world but hey
you're being born and you're saying by
the way just so you know my parents
caused the fire in california to cause
this
and apparently they wanna uh they wanna
get money from the parents
for causing the fire like what are you
gonna do hey parents
of this you know gender reveal you did
here's a bill for you
7.2 billion dollars when are you going
to pay it off you know and that that
voice over was kind of whimsical for
that inside edition story but i mean
think about the people that are now
homeless because of this fire that's a
real real catastrophe
you know it just shows how narcissistic
you are i mean can you think of anything
really right now outside your own family
i mean people are kind of
closing ranks and thinking about
themselves and trying to you know take
care of their own problems but to invite
people
out into a dry grassland just so you can
tell them what your child's sex is gonna
be
how narcissistic those people need to be
punished in some way shape or form
right i mean they talked about pressing
charges but i mean we're not gonna put
them in jail
i don't i don't want to i don't want to
make adam feel uncomfortable because he
told me he wants to one day do the
gender reveal of his child like that i
want to use a machine
he wants to do a flamethrower so
you qualify everybody brings their own
gasoline well i think
i think it's fair to say california
leads amongst all states and narcissists
they produce a lot of narcissists and
empathy
they do good in business but go ahead
just a couple a couple of quick facts um
you mentioned this yesterday this gender
reveal thing has not been around for
decades and decades and decades i think
it's been going on for
you know 10 12 years it started with a a
lady who
slid uh cut into a cake oh the cake's
blue oh my god okay cool
that's what it was supposed to be then
it you know shot off
like a you know kindergartner firework
okay cool no big deal
um but now people are taking machine
guns and pyrotechnics it's
it's out of control but i mean this this
kind of stuff isn't happening
when it comes to the arizona fire
by the way the people did get a bill for
like 8.5 million dollars
the machine gun in arizona and it was a
cop i think who actually did that
now these people in california are
probably going to get a bill but
i found this out 80 of fires these
ridiculous
arson fires are man-made yeah man-made
just idiots you know oh they're smoking
a cigarette they throw it on the ground
so there needs to be some stricter laws
in the west like this doesn't happen on
the east coast
new york city didn't you know go up in
flames because someone had a gender
reveal party it's
obviously the elements of nature and on
the west coast kai you don't want to be
more careful okay you know what i
wouldn't mind doing i wouldn't mind
getting somebody in that world
didn't they make a movie about a
firefighter that they try to put out
these fast fires
movie came out four years ago with
actually a very good actor what was that
movie's name you guys know which one i'm
talking about
just came out three four years ago was
about how to put out fires and
one of the main heroes ends up dying if
anybody's watching this do you remember
that so you see
they could hit like when these just
start yeah i i
here's what i think i think you know
okay you're in california
what is it called only the brave yeah i
remember that it's a good movie by the
way only the break i was thinking when
chuck and larry got married though yeah
that's the kind of movies you would
watch but
you know so but there was also backdraft
back in the days
here's what i think you're in california
every year this time
we have fires every year
this time we have fires okay why don't
you take
math and if it's always have like
can you look up when the fires happen is
it always in september or august because
it's september
it's starting early this year i think
okay so say it's august september
why don't you during that time recruit
i don't know 50 000 firefighters
from other states okay 10 000
firefighters
or reactivate firefighters that were
retired firefighters and put them in
certain spots
just for that two-month period that in
case something were to happen
we get to it immediately california has
access to the smartest brains
and they can't figure this out hey
governor newsom
you know the son-in-law of nancy pelosi
why don't you go bring a meeting
together and have a meeting with the
musks of the world i think he tried to
do something even
the guy prior to was doing it brown he
was trying to do something he actually
put up a meeting together he was
listening to republicans
but why don't you put a meeting together
and figure out how to solve this
everyone's being affected by this i
don't know how many times i've driven on
the 405 freeway you know how you're
coming back from the airport you're
going to the valley
you drive through the 45 freeway adam
fires on both sides
and you're just driving through it's
like you think you're this is normal
this is normal
at this season when when is the season
kai
did you look it up it's the fall i mean
that's when everything's dry you know
you've got a summer of no rain
so you're saying almost having like
national guard out there where they can
respond to
i think so when it's a few hundred acres
they can get it and knock it down before
it turns into ten thousand because if
kai is saying
if adam is saying uh uh uh if adam is
saying does it say season or no made
through october okay
it's summer yeah summer so adam is
saying
eighty percent and i've seen that stat
before eighty percent of five men well
you know where most of them are from the
utility companies pg e
you know where the sparks they have
sparks on the power lines in the merely
remote areas boom the sparks cause these
fires the last three years it's been
i mean billions and billions and
billions of dollars in settlements that
they've had to do i've always thought
why can't you have a little bit more
irrigation underneath the power lines to
make sure that if there are sparks
they're not going to torch
you know 15 communities like the wine
country has just been
devastated the last few years with fires
and these things come in pat
in some of those towns with the winds
that are whipping they'll take out the
entire town
right a town of like four or five
thousand people like nothing standing
all the houses burned down everything
the businesses the houses because you
know they're up against these mountains
and
man it's devastating i don't know look
here's all i know is if you run a
company
and every may through october the same
problem happens
and you don't figure right away to solve
it over 20 year period you're fired yeah
and by the way this is not a small
little costume to the state
this is a big tax to the state that's
the people you mean to tell me you
cannot figure out these fires that are
happening
uh my dad sent me a whole long plant
saying all these aqueducts
you know all these how do you pronounce
it did i pronounce it yeah yeah all
these water
he says you're next to the ocean i
understand if the fires are happening
and you're in the middle of america like
not next to you
look in nebraska and there's no lake no
water right next to the ocean and all
these global warming folks are saying
the ice glaciers are melting which means
you have access to more water because
water ties are coming up
you can't figure out a better system to
solve this thing i don't know i'm not in
that world but hey guys i want to thank
you for getting me excited to go back to
california
thank you by the way there has never
been a better commercial
for california than the first 20 minutes
of this episode